For farmers to really be successful
and to really build with thought
and build something
which will last a long time,
my view is that farmers should
take the time, get to a decision
what they want to build,
begin building it,
really get down the line
of understanding,
really have it well documented
of what they want to build,
how they want to build it.
Avi Eyal,
thank you for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Welcome.
Thank you very much for having me.
I am honored to have you here.
Such a pleasure.
Avi, I can't wait to talk to you
about your journey all the way
from South Africa
with startups all the way
to venture capital.
I'm blown away
by even just saying this,
entrée Capital with over
90 portfolio companies.
23 exits, you told me.
But that's putting aside
the eight fantastic ventures
that you've either exited
or been successful with yourself.
Avi, what gives?
How do you even go
to having such an incredible trajectory?
I have to get into the mindset
of what you went through in your life.
It's just incredible.
So, as a background,
and it's not such a great trajectory,
I think many people
have much greater.
But I was born in Israel
to a very average Israeli family.
My father was in the colonel
in the Air Force,
I used to see him once a week.
And at some stage,
my mother had enough of it.
And at the age of six,
my father took up the role
as an engineer in South Africa
and moved us to South Africa.
And I grew up in South Africa.
In grade one, I met
what became a great friend
and also a business partner of mine,
Martin, and I did my schooling
in South Africa.
Studied engineering
at the University of Natal.
Studied computer engineering
and software engineering,
electrical engineering.
And to put myself through university,
I really didn't know what I was doing.
So, I started a company
writing software to people.
It was the age of ARCNET and Ethernet
starting up and,
and people were writing database's
in dBase and [--] seven.
And I started writing software
for companies
and someone asked me,
"What do you need
to give me an invoice?
What are you going to call
this company of yours?"
So, I didn't have anything better to do
in an age of 18.
I called the great programming solutions
GPX, and that's how the company started.
We became known as Insight Technologies.
By the time I finished university,
we had 50 or 60 employees.
Two years later, we merged into an IPO
in South Africa and then in London.
And really from not knowing any better,
we had a fairly good success
in this business.
I eventually left the business
and had another two startups
that I wanted to try out.
One we sold to
Walmart subsidiary in South Africa,
and the second became
a pretty big property business,
which ended I up being
a shareholder of for 15 years.
But what I realized was that
I needed to leave South Africa
if I wanted to make it big, you know.
Like the actors go to Hollywood
to try and make a big world.
You know, entrepreneurs want
to make a big, we go to the US.
It seems that a couple of other people
were doing the same kind of thing.
Probably much more successful than me,
Elon Musk, Roelof Botha at Sequoia,
seems like they had the same idea.
So, I landed in the US
and I was fortunate enough to,
over the next six years,
be involved in a number of startups
which were sold eventually
to two public companies.
One to private equity business,
and one I sold back to management,
where I learnt a valuable lesson
that if things don't look right
and don't feel right,
and it's much better to exit gracefully.
Get your money back and move on.
And then from there,
I went through a couple of phases.
I went back to South Africa,
got married,
started one more startup,
exited it to a public company in India
and my partner, Martin and I,
who were involved
in the startup as well,
we decided that we'd
start investing in companies.
We had reached
the ripe old age of 40
and everyone was younger,
brighter, faster, stronger.
So, we thought that, you know,
we have a bit of experience
and you know, if we can leverage
our founder experience
to other industries, other startups,
we could leverage that.
And that was the birth of Entrée Capital.
Wow.
Avi, I have to focus a little bit
about this incredible
entrepreneurial experience.
Walk me through some of these
of the key similarities between
the different ventures that you formed.
I think one of the most
fascinating things that I'm gaining
from hearing these incredible stories
is really piecing together some insights
when you look back.
So, if you look back, for example,
in the first venture
that you had during college,
what are some key either mistakes
or incredible insights that you
have gained looking back at it
that you took with you
throughout the rest of your journey?
Sure. Which mistakes didn't I make?
I kind of think
that we were lucky and successful
despite everything we did.
I love it.
The one thing is
we got involved, I always started
in businesses that were moonshots
or at the forefront
of what they were doing.
So, we kind of picked the trend of,
you know, applications,
databases on PCs, moved to Windows
from the old Novell environment,
you know, when networking became
far more accessible
and easier to manage.
So, we leveraged those things
and that was kind of a trend
that followed on when, my second venture
in South Africa was ICOM,
which did which basically took
EDI, which was really old
and really erected an XML
and created XML schemes.
This is a 1995 or so.
Again, what's at the forefront
of what was happening in those days
and sending those messages
across pharmaceutical companies
and big distributors over the Internet
to, in the states where
we had a business,
one of the businesses
was called Maestro Commerce,
where it was really Shopify in 1999.
But you'll appreciate that there wasn't,
there wasn't the ability
to build things at scale in the cloud,
in that first Internet 1.0 operation.
But having said that,
we did very well with it
to [--] DNS
which I was involved in a company
that was taking DNS
and putting it in a software stack
for the first time
and taking it off routers,
Cisco routers and things like that.
Fast forward 15 years later,
I back to business school
NS1 out of New York,
which is kind of
the new generation of DNS.
And NS1 today is probably
the leading company around the world
for application load balancing,
content distribution, DNS,
security and things like that.
And so, a lot of the things
repeat on themselves
in new guises.
Mistakes we made there
kind of not understanding
how to hire the right people,
and not understanding
how to scale business,
being very much
probably a fair amount of arrogance
and kind of building things
around yourself
rather than building things
around teams and releasing.
You know,
typical mistakes that people make
when they don't have
the benefit of expertise
in an ecosystem to use.
And it was one of the biggest
valuable lessons I learned
moving to the states, and that
in South Africa, you were working
as an island, you know.
There wasn't an ecosystem to teach you
how to build great tech companies.
And that's the one thing
that you have to give to Israel,
to London now,
to Boston, New York, San Francisco.
These places have developed
unbelievable ecosystems that,
and certainly in the second iteration
post 2008, of information sharing
and families helping each other.
Jus the plethora of information
that's out there,
whether it's a blog post,
you know, 20 Minute Leadership, etc.,
for people to share information
and not worry about sharing
the information in a way
that it lifts up the entire industry
and makes everyone successful.
100%.
Avi, so, obviously now,
aside from the eight ventures
that you've had,
which are incredible,
you've now also invested
in over 90 portfolio companies.
You've seen a, you know over
a quarter of them exit already.
I have to gauge now,
for young entrepreneurs,
as an entrepreneur myself
and for other young entrepreneurs
starting on their journey,
what are some,
you mentioned about
the power of the ecosystem
and power of the expertise.
So, here's an opportunity for me to talk
to one of the world experts
on startup formation and venture
and venture scaling.
What are some key things
that I should keep in mind
as I go about my venture
or my friends who keep in mind
as they go about theirs
from the early days,
all the way to hiring properly
and scaling it a little bit?
I know it's an incredible
amount to cover,
but the key nuggets
or the key things
that you just keep repeating themselves.
Yes. So, I'm not really an expert. It's,
you know, I offer advice,
and sometimes the advice is right.
but I keep telling people
that past performance is no indicator
of future returns.
I think that too many founders have,
especially in this last year or two,
too many founders
leverage their own brand to go out
and raise incredible amounts of money
because it's easy.
And my thought on it is that
for founders to really be successful
and to really build with thought
and build something
which will last a long time.
My view is that founders
should take their time,
get to a decision
what they want to build,
begin building it,
really get down the line
of understanding,
really have a well documented
on what they want to build,
how they want to build it.
Make decisions on
how they're going to scale,
what those things are going to look
before they raise them
copious amounts of money.
I think they should raise their pre-seed
or their seed around,
they should take time.
They should make sure
they have it right.
Because if you do things right
and if you get to this breakout situation
or moonshots trajectory,
you don't have time
to go back and do things all over.
You don't have time to go back
and correct the sins of the past.
So, my intention is not to be
so influenced by,
oh, I can now raise the seed round.
Six months later, I can raise the A,
and you know, triple the valuation
or quadruple the valuation.
If someone wants to give me
20 million now,
let's quickly take that.
I think it has to be
a bit of thought put into it.
Just because money is there,
money is not the objective.
The objective is
how to build a big company,
a successful venture
that is meaningful to you
and to your stakeholders.
And many times the funding is the,
it is someone else's solution.
It's not the company's best interest.
So, my view is to take it slow,
repeat, build the flywheel,
test, retest and then grow.
And I think that it's a hard thing
to hold yourself back in this market
where money is so cheap.
But I think long term
is best served if you do that.
I think that one of the things
in your touching upon
which I've been very curious about myself
and I've been hearing a lot here,
is this idea of intentionality.
Not just being intentional about,
you know, your team and your product,
but also being intentional about
the growth of your company
and having some
sort of coherent rationality
behind the decisions you make.
And like you're mentioning,
you know, I'm seeing an environment
in which there is a lot of interest
from investors,
there's a lot of interest from advisors
and from people
to want to be part of different journeys,
especially in communities like,
let's say 8200 or Stanford,
but with so many
other communities as well.
And what I'm watching also
is almost like you mentioned,
a lack of intentionality
and a fight for raising
the most amount of capital
or for the biggest names
and the biggest brands.
But without thinking, perhaps,
too critically about
how is this going to help me reach
my next milestone
of making that moonshot impact
or some meaningful impact along the way.
And so, I'm definitely
taking that to heart.
But Avi, I have to ask,
perhaps, one of the most
difficult questions.
You've done so much.
You've had eight incredible ventures.
You have 90 portfolio companies
with 23 exits.
You've run SigmaLabs,
you are on the board member
of Monday.com from the beginning
with so many other companies,
why work more?
Why do you get up
still every day
and work so much
to continue finding more
amazing companies
and spend more time?
You've done it all. Like, seriously.
So, I would beg to differ.
My passion is growing businesses,
growing founders
and I live and breathe it.
I think a lot of people
have done far better.
And it's not a race,
not a comparison.
But if someone built
nine businesses themselves,
you know, if you take,
if you had to compare on Elon Musk,
he's done, you know,
two or three businesses,
got SpaceX, he's got Tesla,
and he's got a few other things.
But just between those two things,
he's done so much more
than I could ever hope to do.
But I suppose in my own way,
I love founders, I love building.
I enjoy the challenge.
I need to be challenged every day.
And for me, it's a combination of
I keep telling my founders, ABC.
Always be closing, you know.
The challenge
that could you be missing out on something.
You know, maybe a bit of avariciousness,
but it's kind of
the need to learn every day.
I'm insatiably thirsty
for information and data and learning.
And also, to be fair,
it's not that I've built 90 or,
the founders have built 90 businesses.
I have partners
and employees who work with me
and the partnership has built
90 successes.
I maybe the front face
of the partnership
but everyone in our business
works really hard
and really does extraordinarily well.
And maybe I think
maybe the success has been
that insatiability
or that appetite to build
and not to miss out to
and to help and to grow,
I think has maybe rubbed it off
on the three or four key people
in our business
that write the checks.
Right. I have to say that even beyond
the incredible trajectory,
I'm even more inspired
by the humbleness that you portray here.
And obviously,
there are phenomenal people
that are working
on a lot of these endeavors.
But at the end of the day,
you mentioned that you didn't create
those 90 companies yourself,
but, you know,
finding those 90 companies
and then finding the right founders
and having that joint partnership
and providing value
that both sides are happy,
i think that's inspiring for me to say.
I see so many partnerships of friends,
either from the venture capital world
or founding partners
or advisors that provide less value
than anyone expected
or even have deteriorating effect.
And I think that finding
the right partners, to me,
it seems like you're growing
as the biggest part here,
in creating that venture.
And I think that anybody
who's been working with you
is incredibly lucky.
But Avi, a little bit
about finding the right founders.
Both founders and perhaps co-founders.
So, you've seen now, you know,
over 100 companies that you
have personally been involved with,
thousands more that you've observed.
What are some interesting insights
as to, either backing the right founders
or for a founder,
finding the right partners
to go on the journey with?
So, finding the right partners for us
is has been
a really challenging thing to do.
I think that we come from a background
where all of our partners
are quite technical.
They have very well-formed ideas
of what they believe in.
They, I would say
about my partners is that
they all have
the highest morals and ethics.
And to become a partner,
we have to work with someone
for a long time
and we have to know them
for a long time.
And it's kind of that's always
a challenge to get to the right place.
From a founders
and company perspective,
we kind of created a formula
of how we look at businesses
and how we look at founders
from a business perspective,
we call it the four Ts
where we created a formula
which is timing, tick,
TAM, and team.
So, the founders individually are important,
but the founders no good
if they can't work on a team.
Right.
And so, when I look at you as a founder,
I equally look at your co-founders.
And my test is,
if the founders, together,
can work on a team.
Right.
We don't like compromising on people
with that may not have
absolute integrity or,
you know, ethics or things like that.
I think all too often
people overlook certain challenges
that founders have
because they make it up
by, the idea is great
or something else.
But my view is that
you want to be in partners
with the people you go into business with.
And for us, we kind of
set our founders that
we are founders alongside them.
You know, we are entrepreneurs,
which is very different.
And because as entrepreneurs,
we can't see any of our businesses
in any other way
than from an entrepreneur's eyes.
And so, we want to be
an entrepreneur with you
rather than a financial investor in you.
Yes, we give you money
and yes, we expect to have great returns.
But we want to be
on the journey with you.
And so,
we find that kind of that alignment
works out very well.
And I think we've become very quick
at identifying if you are not fit.
And so, we can say no quite quickly.
But we also get to yes, very quickly.
I love that.
Avi, I have to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
And obviously,
I know how incredibly busy you are
and it's phenomenal having you here.
Thank you for the inspiration
and for the insights
and for making a positive impact.
I'm just looking
at the different companies
that either you've build
or that you've helped become
a founding partner, as you're saying.
And I think it's just remarkable
and just that impact on the world
and that insatiable curiosity
that you talk about
is something that I identify
with very closely,
both with my family,
but also with myself.
And I think that I'm getting
the most inspiration
out of those two words
from this conversation.
But before we leave, I have to ask you
the most important
and difficult question,
which is three words
that you would use describe yourself.
Is this in terms of business
or in terms of personal?
I'm going to let you decide that.
Let's say if I ask one of your partners
or one of the founders
that you've backed,
who is Avi Eyal,
what are some words
that they would say about you?
Okay. Then I think they would tell you
thoughtful, integrity and loyalty.
I love that.
And you forgot also
the two most important words,
insatiable, curious.
But I think that
I'm going to have [--] in that.
[--]
Avi, toda raba.
Thank you very, very much.
And I look forward to keeping in touch.
And it's just incredible.
Thank you.
I really appreciate you
having me on the show.